you have the best use of sprinkles in a
movie since serendipity best use of
sprinkle SSS uses sprinkles
it's your favorite ice cream because I
have an ice cream personality test for
you oh I like a cookie dough ice cream a
double dark chocolate like an expresso
II almost like yeah
strawberry look that is it that is a
close tie between mint chocolate chip
bad choice okay I'm gonna pretend I
didn't hear that
ramen raisin oh that's not even on my
list you're just a renegade now I just
just add wrong cookie dough means you're
generous actually I'm generous how so
like to like to give wherever it's my
time kind of a sucker for coffee okay
coffee means you're dramatic which is
perfect because you're an actor make
your bow
boo mean chocolate means you're
flirtatious it doubly chases me is it
true he's pretty devastating I'm gonna
tell you thanks you're an introvert is
that true yeah it is an interesting
thing because my career choices so they
upset
John's character has a scene with some
ice cream and some sprinkles was he
doing that was that with the moon is
that you bring it out and you pray that
it gets on that ice cream I'm more of a
sprinkle you get it in your hand and you
go I think I would take the sprinkles
and I like oacute oh I love that you
could create your own Jager in real life
that was sort of very you what would it
be like it should be wearing heels
probably wouldn't move very well and it
has like a karaoke room with a singing
Jager a giant version of vanilla ice
freezing
[Music]